bastareaud va
[Applaudissements]
présenter le congrès des états unis
beaucoup de respect et d'admiration pour
votre courage mesdames et messieurs les
membres du concret et l'insigne honneur
de vous présenter le président de
l'ukraine volodymyr
sava aucun lien
makaridze soit va encore leur collègue
cela va au crânien
moi j'ai
gilles anglais qui parlent anglais
mesdames et messieurs
américain
je suis fier de vous saluer de l'ukraine
de notre capitale kiev une ville qui
fait face aux bombardements aux missiles
aux attaques des forces russes chaque
jour mais est une ville qui ne baisse
pas les bras
et cela ne nous traverse même pas
l'esprit
comme c'est le cas de beaucoup d'autres
villes et communautés de notre beau pays
qui se trouve dans la pire hier depuis
la deuxième guerre mondiale j'ai
l'honneur de vous saluer au nom du
peuple ukrainien
au nom d'un peuple qui aime la liberté
qui pendant huit ans a résisté à
l'agression russe
ce qui donne leurs meilleurs fils leur
meilleure fille pour faire face à une
invasion russe de grande ampleur à
l'heure actuelle le sort de notre pays
se décide le destin de notre peuple
le fait de savoir si les ukrainiens
seront libres capables de préserver leur
démocratie la russie n'a pas seulement
attaquer nos villes est notre terre la
russie a lancé une attaque importante
sur nos valeurs sur les valeurs humaines
par ses tanks ses chars et ses avions
elle porte atteinte à notre liberté de
choisir notre propre avenir
c'est une attaque contre notre
désir de bonheur cela va à l'encontre de
nos rêves nationaux les rêves que vous
formez vous même vous américain
tout comme quiconque aux états unis
je j'ai à l'esprit le mémorial de
rochemaure les visages de ces américains
de ces présidents qui ont jeté les bases
de la démocratie américaine
une démocratie libre et indépendante qui
prend soin de tous de tous ceux qui
travaillent avec sérieux avec honnêteté
qui respectent la loi nous souhaitons la
même chose en ukraine pour notre peuple
tout cela fait partie de la vie normale
de tout citoyen mesdames et messieurs
chers amis chers américain dans votre
grande histoire
vous avez
pu comprendre
l'ukraine et vous comprenez l'ukraine à
l'heure actuelle
souvenez-vous de pearl harbor
un terrible matin de décembre 1942
lorsque le ciel s'est obscurci d'avion
qui vous ont attaqué rappelez vous du 11
septembre
un jour noir
ou une de vos villes a été attaqué
lorsque un nouveau territoire a été muet
en champ de bataille où des innocents
ont péri attaqué désert
pers on ne s'y attendait et vous n'avez
pas pu parer cette attaque est bien
notre pays fait face aux mêmes
événements tous les jours en ce moment
même nous faisons face à cela depuis
trois semaines
des villes nombreuses marioupol lui font
face à ces attaques
le ciel ukrainien s'est mué en source de
mort pour des milliers de personnes les
troupes russes
ont déjà tiré mille missiles sur les
villes ukrainiennes des bombes ont été
utilisés pour tuer nos citoyens c'est
une terreur que nous n'avions pas
observé depuis 80 ans
c'est une terreur qui doit être
ressentie par le monde entier
nous devons protéger le ciel ukrainien
pour protéger les citoyens une
est ainsi la russie ne pourra pas
continuer à terroriser nos villes libres
si c'est trop demander eh bien nous
proposons une alternative
nous
vous savez de quel système de défense
aérienne nous avons besoin
nous
nous avons besoin d'une aviation
puissante pour protéger notre peuple
notre terre notre liberté
ainsi vous pourrez aider des ukrainiens
vous pourrez aider l'europe
vous savez que ces systèmes existent et
vous en disposez mais malheureusement
ils sont sur le sol ils ne sont pas dans
les airs mais
j'ai un rêve et vous connaissez cette
expression eh bien je formule aveux moi
même j'ai un besoin j'ai besoin de votre
décision de votre aide
et je ressens ces mots tout comme ce que
vous ressentez lorsque vous écoutez les
paroles j'ai un rêve l'ukraine s'est gré
aux états unis pour son soutien
pour eux tout ce que votre gouvernement
et votre peuple ont fait pour nous qu'il
s'agisse d'armes de munitions de
formation de financement et de
leadership du monde libre ce qui nous a
permis à faire pression sur la partie
adverse et je sais gré au président by
donne pour son aide et pour son
engagement sincère à défendre la
démocratie ukrainienne et la démocratie
partout dans le monde et je suis
et je ressens de la gratitude pour la
résolution adoptée pour pouvoir traduire
les criminels de guerre en justice
néanmoins à l'heure la plus sombre dans
laquelle nous vivons
j'en appelle à vous afin que vous en
fassiez davantage davantage de sanctions
jusqu'à ce que la machine de guerre
russes s'arrête des restrictions doivent
peser sur tous ceux qui sont proches du
régime nous proposons que les sanctions
américaines frappe tous les hommes et
femmes politiques de la fédération de
russie
qui reste à leur fonction
est de
mettre fin aux liens que vous avez avec
tous ceux qui sont responsables de cette
agression
nous devons mettre à ce terrorisme
d'état toutes les entreprises doivent
quitter la russie quitter le marché
russe sur le champ
car
ce ces autorités ont du sang sur les
mains
mesdames et messieurs si vous avez des
entreprises dans votre district qui
finance des parties russe et bien vous
devez faire pression vous devez vous
assurer à ce que les russes ne reçoivent
aucun centime qu'ils puissent être
utilisés pour détruire l'ukraine la
destruction de notre pays la destruction
de l'europe
toute l'amérique doit se fermer aux
produits russes nous devons défendre ce
principe dans le monde entier
nous avons déjà constaté une coalition
anti guerre qui a animé plusieurs pays
dans la rue
contre cette décision de poutine d'un
vahid envahir notre pays mais nous
devons faire davantage nous devons
élaborer de nouveaux outils pour réagir
rapidement et mettre un terme à cette
invasion de grande ampleur de la russie
qui s'est déclenchée le 24 février
va prendre fin le plus tôt possible
à l'heure actuelle
le monde ne dispose pas de tels outils
nos prédécesseurs ont créé des
institutions
conçu pour nous protéger de la guerre
néanmoins malheureusement ces
institutions sont inopérantes nous avons
besoin de nouvelles institutions de
nouvelles alliances
nous proposons de créer une
association une union de paix
irresponsables pour la paix
afin de pouvoir mettre un terme au
conflit immédiatement afin de pouvoir
acheminer toute l'assistance nécessaire
aux 24 heures kisa s'agisse d'armes de
sanction de soutien politique de
financement quels que soient les moyens
pour pouvoir assurer la paie rapidement
pour pouvoir sauver le monde sauvé des
vies
une telle association une telle union
pourrait apporter une évaluation à ceux
qui font face aux catastrophes
aux crises humanitaires
rappelez vous convient-il it combien il
était difficile de mobiliser les
énergies pour trouver un vaccin afin de
sauver des vies
le monde a passé des années
pour parvenir à de tels efforts pour
pouvoir préserver les vies mesdames et
messieurs chers américain
si une telle alliance
existait aujourd'hui
nous serions capables de sauver des
milliers de vie dans notre pays et dans
beaucoup de pays du monde
beaucoup deux personnes ont besoin de
cette paix ceux qui souffrent de
destruction inhumaine
je vous demande d'ouvrir les yeux sur ce
que font les russes dans notre
territoire nous devons y mettre à terme
devons empêcher la destruction
perpétrés par tout agresseur qui cherche
à soumettre d'autres nations je vous
invite à regarder cette vidéo
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
où
voilà l'intervention de volodymyr
zelensky qui se poursuit au congrès
américain le président ukrainien qui
diffusa à présent une vidéo sur sur la
guerre depuis 21 jours en ukraine avec
moi en plateau virginie hertz elana
volochine notre correspondante à moscou
qui est aujourd'hui ici à paris on
retiendra que volodymyr zelensky
renouvelle son appel à une zone
d'exclusion aérienne au dessus de
l'ukraine
il dit au congrès américain qu'il faut
plus de sanctions aussi contre les
responsables politiques russes qui
soutiennent l'invasion
voilà papillon vient de se terminer
peut-être que le mien ce qui va
reprendre la parole et on déblaie fera
bien sûr son discours
et enfin
pour conclure
aujourd'hui
il ne suffit pas d scrutant leur pelouse
une nation
il fipa d'être
dirigeants du monde il convient d'être
le dirigeant
de la paix cela ne dépend pas seulement
de votre peuple mais aussi de ceux qui
vivent à côté de vous de ceux qui sont
puissants mais être puissant
cela
veut dire se battre pour la vie des
citoyens la vie des citoyens du monde
pour la liberté pour le droit de vivre
en paix lorsque
leur viendra
ne se pas faire dicter des ordres par
ses voisins
aujourd'hui le peuple ukrainien ne
défend pas seulement l'ukraine il se bat
pour les valeurs de l'europe et du monde
et ce au nom de l'avenir
aujourd'hui le peuple américain ne
n'êtes pas seulement le peuple ukrainien
il aide le monde ancien entier à
préserver la justice
j'ai presque 45 ans
mais
ce cet âge
je ne prend plus en compte depuis que
sans enfant retrouvé la mort
nous devons mettre fin à ces mort c'est
ma principale mission en tant que
dirigeant de mon pays en tant que
dirigeant des ukrainiens
et en tant que dirigeant de ma nation je
m'adresse au président baden
vous êtes également
chef d'un état
mais j'en appelle à votre leadership
mondial à leadership pour la paix je
vous remercie cela va obtenir
[Applaudissements]